こんにちははじめ雪はです皆さんぽうモンカードはやってますでしょうか
なんだめっブーブーんでめっちゃ周りの人とかいろんな人がやっててポケモンカードの
ルールすごい簡単で覚えやすいんですけど最初お互いてる店前から始まるんですよなら
ない
沿ってくだバーってみた時にポケモンがいないとダメなんですよポケモンとポケモンを
戦わせカードゲームなんてポケモンがいないと戦いか
始まらないんでこの時点でもう一回やり直しになりますをシャッフルしてまた7枚引く
読みたいっていうことなんで結構ポケモンカードにおいてデッキの中にポケモンを
たくさん入れておくというのはすごい大事なことなんですけども結構めちゃくちゃ
プルオーバーやってておりかやってるうちに思ったことは良い
意外とというのはポケモンがこないことが多いんですよみんなやってる時結構3回連続
来なかったりすることが
あってなんかトレーナーとかグッズとかってすごい強力なんでこういうのをたくさん
入れがちな人がすごい応援ってどう糞塊
もし俺のポケモンカードがデッキポケモンがいなかったらと霧をやっていると思います
本当にポケモン行い来てなんか入りませんでしたもう一回いませんでしたもう1体と
言う結構マジであるんで僕バレないと思うと一気にポケモンが入ってなくてもこれに
どう
てぐらい早く気づけるかちょっと検証してみたいと思いますねちょっとこういう
ポケモンたちですねポケモン県全部抜きます
はいというわけで映るできたらポケモンがいいだけだってしまいましたたださせずに
0度と怪しまれるん
大衆的に来て出せるポケモンって進化しないポケモンか
進化前のポケモンしか出せないんですよ例えばピカチュウは出せるけど雷2はダメ
みたいな感じで寝具せる plone たせませんなんでこういう進化が必要な
ポケモン時入れるんですけどもこれが的なに来た
出せないんで結局シャッフルしなおし実質ポケモンゼロのできるございます果たして
いくらポケモンが逸品を出せねえ的でなんか意味でターゲットアーム的にポケモンがい
ないことに気づくの換金していきたいとおもいます
じゃじゃんっどうだがー
ぽぽぽを
利益においても
小屋突破ほんとどうもどうぞふーっ
ねちょっと戦略がわかったかもできるああ
100が出ます設定ざいた
夢が進みます
たらしい接触じゃんけんぽん
写真号
[音楽]
ん
ミッキん
うん
しています
f えっ
なんかここがいいねぇよくあるじゃねって自分
ねこれ
[音楽]
いやーアテネ味がしてもじゃあはまず java やまだまだ
3回ぐらいのまだ許容範囲
うんっ
ha
俺はぁ
eme
ヤバメ茶どうぞと思います
まんってホントにやめてください
安いですね
じゃあまたあたってい
me
あって聖剣カットセット
カップで売りれていました
a はいじゃなかっ
裏1 e c o 4 s 棟2
アート空北歩こうパート麻生ぱ
se
万てあーはっはっは
全部なんです立っていやぁーます
dec 22
待ってやわーいーいーやおやし私がほしいですからキロ
襲われたことができました見えてないよねっ
ん
つきません
[音楽]
感じます0阿部が食べたら
はぁっ
をはいじゃあと言う者だと思います hot pot やったらええっ
ええええええはシェアはう
まあまだ魚が18枚ですよ
ものまで美味しいですです
[音楽]
ペーパー弱い増山これなんですまぁざっての一しねえちゃん456な
1回やり直します全部これこう言ってやり次第でそりゃあ
ルールに基づいてないんでそこからうちらは the ちゃんと酔いしれる
一応
ええええい
4 r
凄腕 a
始めてみたらこんなん
やすげーなー
待ってマジやばいなので
[音楽]
をアツシって持った
ワンタンん
8分
そんなことありますみんなことがあるはいえええ
だからなのであればできた風速何ですか
不思議ですねぇいい
いい
本当に入っている8わかりましたよ
エットってますね
アジアさん
[音楽]
car
me
バッハ
何回目でるっきんポケモンがいないことを息づかって言ってるでした
靴う
うーん何やってですから気づかなかったですデッキの構築見せたやなぁって面白いです
よ